[Music]
bachelor couple Ben Higgins and Lauren
Bushnell have called it quits but were
the signs right in front of us here's a
few interesting things the Bears told eg
since they first got engaged I know this
happened weeks ago but your rewatching
it you're like wait like like you're
cheating on me or somebody it's not fun
to like watch your fiance
kissing other women months later the
couple announced their reality show a
Ben and Lauren a happily ever after
we're gonna go today for a first session
as a couple and we're gonna therapy
couples therapy because I think it you
know for as much as time as we spend
together I don't know you know if it is
there's things we need to know about
each other I think that would really
help but she's marriage in itself is
weird a month later they enjoyed an
engagement bash in Vegas and told eg
this about their bachelor and
bachelorette parties we're doing things
out of order I get that sometimes it's
not ideal in think how things happen but
the bachelor and bachelorette parties
wanted to be shown on Ben and Lauren
happily ever after and for that to
happen it had to be you know last week
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas
no it wasn't yeah it wasn't I mean the
girls weren't crazy like I can't speak
for the guys the next month they made a
shocking revelation on their reality
show - you're saying the wedding is off
yeah I am the weddings on hold right now
at this point are you talking wedding
dates again um
happy wedding day uh um again honestly
like it is on old we haven't necessarily
discussed an exact wedding date what has
been the best thing about doing this
reality show and what has been the
hardest thing about it
best thing I mean we've gotten to spend
a lot of time together and I think that
also sometimes could be like the worst
thing in a way because we haven't really
had our space and both of us are really
independent people in January they still
didn't have a date so is that your new
answer people bug you about the wedding
question you say we're getting a dog
I just divert I divert to the animal
naturally when we were filming our new
show it was hard on us we were tired and
there was a lot of things coming up in
our life as we got to know each other
that was then being displayed on
television which caused a level of
emotional like desperation we were also
with them just last month we get it like
people are interested in we're getting
married we're excited for that day we're
excited to be together but we don't know
we don't know and that's for a lot of
reasons right our life is is pretty
crazy and we're having a blast being
engaged and enjoying that time without
having the stresses of planning a
wedding on top of it
[Music]
you